you guys have probably heard
that women make rules for men that they
deem to be
beta and they'll break them for men that
they deem to be alpha
now there's a lot of debate out there
about
oh alpha sigma beta you know be this be
that it's like
these are placeholder terms okay i mean
i feel like sometimes i shouldn't have
to explain this but i'm going to explain
it
because people always get all bent out
of shape
it's a placeholder term beta less
desirable
weaker society doesn't you know look
fondly upon doesn't
relish you know sort of stuff alpha
strong virtuous
masculine women want to be with them men
want to be them sort of thing you know
if they're not them they get pissed off
and sometimes they go down the
doom pill path but at the end of the day
the debate is irrelevant there are men
that women deem to be alpha
and there's men that women deem to be
beta so since they're the sexual
selectors let's defer to them
for point and case in this
bit that i want to cover now
so there's cute little good girl
librarians that will make you wait
patiently
three months for basic missionary when
you were 20
but she'll end up in bed with chad 15
minutes after meeting him
at the foam cannon party in ibiza on her
23rd birthday with her girlfriends right
now you can be certain that she'll do
everything that she said she wouldn't do
with you with him
right never forget that women will break
rules for alphas and make them for betas
so
when a woman says something like i don't
do that
in your head if she's saying i don't do
that she's basically moving you more
towards the beta category
and you need to add in your head with me
so if you say something to her like i
want to do this in a bedroom or i want
to introduce this in the bedroom let's
do that
you know the intimacy level stuff let's
just deal with that more specifically
and she says i don't do that then in
your head you have to insert with
me okay because she will go through
those
sexual gymnastics with the chat
they'll always break rules for an alpha
and make them for beta
it's always been that way let me tell
you the story about
uh the amazonia and i think this is
covered in a little more detail on a
couple of pages of the book but
rather than reading i'll just tell it to
you so i had this date with this chick
that showed up and
my height cap is i don't know i'm gonna
say five
nine ish or so five like anything more
than five ten it's like
i don't want a sasquatch right i like
you know
buck thirty buck thirty five pounds you
want a bit of a spinner you can pick
them up and
you know anyway she shows up she's about
six foot tall she never said
that was her height of course you know
it's a dating app so the pictures are
old it's
the right angle you know the different
angles and all you saw was
boobies and you're like okay you know
let's grab a drink but
this chick shows up and she's about six
foot tall she's probably about
25 pounds heavier than what her pictures
looked and older of course because the
pictures are
from five years ago but she's still
really really cute so she's still
solid enough to like i'm there let's
just grab this drink and get the hell
out of here
this was an interesting one though i
actually enjoyed this conversation
and this is just one part of the
conversation that was functional so
don't always dismiss somebody that shows
up
um not with your expectations you know
sometimes you can still get something
out of the conversation
anyway so this is where i got the um
women will make rules
for betas and break them for alphas and
they'll flip back and forth sometimes
depending on how you pass the [ __ ] test
and she said to me um you know within a
few moments of sitting down that she had
this like eight date rule she won't
sleep with anybody unless it's eight
dates
i'm like okay here we go here we go
already she's trying to negotiate desire
when things are gonna happen and captain
bossypants all because she had
some bad experiences in the past right
so you're sitting there listening to her
lecture you about how she's gonna make
you wait eight dates like as if i care i
mean i wasn't even
particularly interested in her at this
point but
i'm like look i don't negotiate when
these things happen
and i don't follow these silly rules it
gets in the way of intimacy
give her a few more sound bites of this
and that basically told her to pound
sand
and she takes a swig of her drink and
she had she had her boobs in this
low-cut top
with a big push-up kit going on i'm not
sure what was going on with the push-up
kit but it was pretty solid but there
was a big huff there
she takes a sip and she says all right
let's go bang in the bathroom
and then gestures over to the washroom
in the bar now
i don't normally turn away aggressive
advances like this but this is one of
the few times in my life that i did
and i just laughed i you know i just
thought to myself
two three minutes ago you're lecturing
and setting limits around when intimacy
is going to happen based on your
schedule based on your experiences
because this is the way that you want to
do things
and what she's essentially doing is
she's [ __ ] testing me
she's trying to find out what this guy
is all about because women will do this
right like they'll always
look competency tests i'm going to try
to avoid swearing as much as possible
because
it is you know the youtubes so she's
going to competency test you is this guy
beta is this guy alpha i'm not sure you
know
he looks like he's losing his hair maybe
he's a bit of a dork i'm not sure if i
dig his vibe let me [ __ ] test him so she
throws these lyrics at me
and i knock him out of the park and then
she wants to go and use the bathroom
as her own private brothel so it can
flip very very quickly in this case it
happened within a matter of like 20
minutes
right these are the kinds of things that
women do and you have to understand that
um if you want to have her best if you
want to have a good experience around
women you of course want to operate in
an alpha frame
there's alpha frame there's beta frame
and there's some stuff kind of in
between you know
some people go in segment omega and
they'll make up all these other new
categories
just keep it simple okay alpha seed beta
need
anyway guys that operate in a beta frame
will get cheated on far
far more than alpha males they get left
they get divorced more often
this is just what ends up happening
right she doesn't view the guy
as his best it's just a horrible
horrible way
to be in a relationship you see these
guys you know
i bet right now there's somebody here
watching it's like uh i don't want to
run into
bob or bill or matt at thanksgiving or
over the holidays because i don't have
to deal with his crap and his misery
with his miserable
relationship you know what i'm talking
about you do not want to be
converted into a beta
you